hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay we just
killed a big monster and then a ship
crashed into us so we're going to go try
to find a way under that ship because
Hammond is on well Hammond is back for
one he's alive which I'm glad to see but
now he's on his way back to try and find
a way on the ship because we need to get
a singularity court to put into a shovel
and get off this place oh yeah good
memory alright now we ride the longest
elevator in the world back down and we
go out oh I got two guys I'm jazzed up I
just I'm not jazzed up who's out there
Oh who's out there who Oh No
jump yeah fall apart
you just falling apart man take a chill
pill there we go
yeah like that was difficult oh hello
you dropped a bunch of goodies what no
no rubies semiconductor now where am I
going
okay back out what was that I heard
something oh well that's that's no good
that's not good at all how is that stuff
growing how is it growing on metal
I mean it's organic but even organic
stuff can't just reproduce from nothing
they need organic material to reproduce
or so I I think man whatever I've
stopped trying to make sense of this
this whole deal a long time ago there it
is I'll keep ya out of here out of here
out of here line rack no I'll contact
energy nope alright force energy no uh
flame fuel get out of here
no need you oh I got so much money so
much money all right
oh but power nodes so some reason I
don't know and no I'm not gonna buy any
other weapons hahahaha okay
Oh huh
oh hello fatty you're on go
what Oh where's your head go hahahaha
pwned
oh you didn't even spit out your babies
no get take that little ones anymore
anymore wanna mess with me the answer is
no come on on the tram I know they're
gonna put something in this tram
sometime ha ha not not this time though
booyah another chapter down I'm the man
search and rescue gone so much for that
God a military ship being taken down by
one Necromorph how is that possible huh
whatever cargo hold
okay that looks like a big section
that's about the biggest section that
I've gone to so far that size is huge
hmm well I guess since it's a mining
ship the cargo hold does need to be huge
in order to hold all the asteroids and
stuff like that process minerals alright
what horrors await me now whoa hey get
inside I just found the munitions log
for the valor I don't think their
presidency has the coincidence they're
not on reconnaissance and then not on
Patrol this ship is prepped for war
they're on a secret story missions oh
come on I think I've lost him again no
signal from Hammonds rig find a
singularity core and get the hammer when
I find dr. Mercer I'm gonna do like dumb
enough teach him a thing or two him I
slap him around show him who's boss
that's me in case you were wondering
okay anyway well if they were prepped
for war they should have been ready for
that but what ever man F I'm upgrading
my help to de max I'll crank it up to 11
there we go three left over cuz I'm a
bow there we go good enough still got
two left over food demand oh look at all
the bars on my back
all right what are we doing huh door I
don't have anything to sell really ha ha
boom all right well nothing so far I
know they like to put things right
behind me
yeah didn't think so
oh here we go green glowing ball yeah
yeah no weapons ripped open in the crash
those green orbs you see are highly
radioactive oh and the Valerie's airlock
has sealed itself you're going to have
to throw this into space before you can
get into the ship okay sounds good to me
I hope my suit is radioactive proof but
he's gonna open ya these old big ol
airlock so I can throw them out
yep there we go yeah here don't you get
sucked out mom get and what done you
serious you serious you serious right
now
there you go very serious with me hey do
active material remove ruin who's that
what happened to the ladies [ __ ] active
material remote computer ah what the
hell what what where where oh you really
you're not even a black one so don't
even think you have a chance with me
that's right get out of here all right
give me you
I'll give me you yeah that's my pickup
line for girls give me you no it's not
that's his creepy come on here we go is
there another one monster
oh I don't take a box no you're not
getting away baby
let's up my other pick-up line notice
that you're not getting away from me
baby
yeah I'm persistent oh I need air air
air air thank you no thank you
Oh black one I like you gonna do any
different oh okay oh man you are just
persistent huh huh huh
there we go surgical precision all right
um where's it lie there's one cover nada
no that's wrong
oh don't tell me I'm too far away you
got to be kidding me
no get out of here Necromorph material
otherwise known as that if you are
material removed give me some air I need
to get over there apparently what blue
flying hooter here
there's my Geiger counter Oh Valerie oh
that's okay I know what we're doing now
oh no no don't bounce off get out get up
yes
cereal remove all bank shot
boss okay now aim aim aim and shoot good
hey what up up not whoosh I am away
can't touch this
would you go where are you wait what did
that Oh baby I see you I can't come to
me not dead in the air
give me that give it uh I need air
I saw that nope nope nope too late
nope and you get a stomp I get back and
get your stomping ha ha ha Wow get your
stomping I'm gonna are you son of a
hmm right right
gimme a I need that all right what am i
doing now my leaving oh I'm leaving okay
go over there
jump but jompa do you okay was there
light is there like some secret around
here that I could like get that's
secretive
let's dude there I get through there
nope Kanna
okay let's see on the Valor who oriental
I'm guessing the e Schumer is an
oriental ship as well but this one
definitely ha ha whoa what the heck was
that kind of fast
the part you're looking for will be in
the engine room at the back of the ship
uh-huh
I'm reading massive damage so you may
need to find an alternate route to get
there
no kidding okay what I want to know is
how anything is still working on this
ship how is the issue Mora still in the
air if another should just crash into it
I don't know the size difference of
these ships well all your dead body aah
whoa whoa
twitchy hey what the heck wrong with you
nope you're not dead a little don't
trust you
don't trust you okay
that guy was twitchy infection process
is doing something strange these
soldiers they all have built-in stasis
units in their body armor the infection
is merging the stasis unit into that
question ah yeah making them move fast
real fast real fast how is Hammond doing
he doesn't even have armor maybe he does
I don't know well I guess if an engineer
can survive surely a trained soldier
could ha ha that's laughable just
looking at this whole ship oh my god I
went the wrong way
oh I do not like mazes do not like me
get out here you get good out of here
good out of here no huh
I saw that get ready for your lumps all
your lumps my home's your lumps get okay
huh how'd you get out you were in there
you were trapped in here with me ah nope
nope Oh nugget balls I see you I see you
nope not today well that was it you just
felt hi
nope nope this is your quick to collect
bunnies anyone else want a mess anyone
no didn't think so what ha hey OH
man this assault rifle is good because
it just locks them up they just stand
there and twitch wash riddled them with
bullets so not bad not bad at all
get out of my way I'm so strong
telekinesis [ __ ]
uh what telekinesis [ __ ] what whoa oh
yeah whoa
I saw a skull yeah she got pretty sure
she's dead she's got to be dead
Isaac's hallucinating losing his mind
and she's dead all this backed up
they're hiding a secret hiding us I a me
no no no no locked up and do nothing
that's great stone yeah all right yeah
yeah I meant I'm sorry please excuse me
I need to bypass you sorry I slipped
into Swedish a bit
what is this powering just that light
that's all that was powering really I
think that's a waste of a giant battery
don't you think hey Isaac I'm tracking
your position but it doesn't look like I
can reach you
no of course this damn ship was nearly
[ __ ] yeah I made it to the bridge it's a
mess here yep these poor bastards didn't
stand a chance why not right old door
lock so you can get to the engine room
next soldier there why didn't they send
in Japan
don't trust you sorry son didn't trust
you yeah take that okay
alright I have it tap this y'all doing
doing doing doing doing doing yes
override I want oh why did I need to
bring this
did I not need to bring this Oh God
alright whatever whatever
that's one oh hi alright where you give
up no know what I know
oh that's why I stopped up the bodies
you can't make more infect them with
your infecting juices yeah okay now I
can stuff this in here point like that
there are supposed to go okay what's
this way then hello cargo room oh
there's a whole lot of nothing well
that's interesting
alright going here
Oh an elevator yay how nice oh I need to
speak with you well are you my name is
Taryn Skye well thank you very much
you're sorry listen to man no that isn't
much time there's lots of time if you
really can repair the shuttle I care
about a wall to use for it than just
running away no you must understand the
forces at work here on greater than you
can imagine not as good as me you leave
now you can get all humanity not don't
we never stop never rest unless the
marker is returned don't you see no a
dog is wrong this is all a trap I've
seen it well that was weird huh oh hey
buddy buddy you don't look so good you
want to come down and help me fight
these things are you just gonna stand
there and relax lay there and be
tortured I guess alright alright you go
do your thing I won't bug you
you seem pretty busy what's that don't
trust ya what
I thought I heard something big I
probably did hear something big give me
that oh yeah
stop screaming guy you're confusing me
I'm trying to listen out for enemies you
know an actual threat what wow
not mother you've got you know up no not
going anywhere
yep yep yep what no no get back get back
get back
I'm running I'm running running running
running running try just try come
through that door
oh crap the red on the other side of the
door aren't they crap I'm almost out of
ammo - I need to switch to the pistol
here for just a little bit ah reload ha
yeah ha boom whoa ha ha God good yeah
boom boom got ya got ya kids game so
tough manly handsome all of the above
our node I don't need that right now
it's probably upgrade by you know super
pistol just here just in case no bad
stuff happens
which it will it is not a grill haha
have weapons ready and fire it will ya
only took all of five minutes for you
all to lose
good job their God their job their
buckaroos what's this um shooting range
I want to try let me try
haha got ya I've infinite bullets this
ha boom ha ha boom
[ __ ] yeah I'm going way over time sorry
about this guys but I gotta cut it here
thank you guys so much for watching as
always I will see you in the next part
bye bye ah